[Musik]
es war einmal so beginnt so manches
märchen am anfang schuf gott himmel und
erde
so beginnt die bibel herzlich willkommen
in der sternstunde religion wenn es um
märchen und religion geht ist eugen
drewermann
der mann der stunde der theologe und
psychotherapeut hat auf tausenden von
seiten die welt der märchen insbesondere
der märchen der brüder grimm erkundet
warum sollten wir den eugen drewermann
diese märchen heute noch lesen weil sie
uns als erwachsenen mehr zu sagen haben
denn damals da wir kinder waren die
märchen sind die einzige rzr gattung der
weltliteratur die daran glaubt und
glauben machen möchte
das einzig die liebe im stande sei uns
glücklich werden zu lassen wohin sie
sonst schauen haben sie geschichten wie
die bei shakespeare romeo und julia
diejenigen die die liebe riskieren
werden scheitern aus tödliche würde sich
in unserer normalen welt wie sie in der
zeitung abgebildet wird das ereignen
wovon die märchen volle sind ein
königssohn liebte eine bürgerliche würde
es so ähnlich werden wie um 1300 als
maximilian die an das bernauer ins
schloss und die hof schrank sind fanden
werden er den abstand der stände
verringern will und möchte tatsächlich
nicht nur eine mätresse sondern eine
ehefrau aus anis bernauer machen muss
hier eine hexe sein die ihn um den
verstand gebracht hat so wird er sorgt
bei straubing wie eine katze die märchen
glauben dass das wahnsinn ist was wir
für normal halten dass die welt in der
wir existieren ein gefängnis ist
ausmacht aus geldgier aus einer fremden
aus uneigentlich keiten in jeder form
die psychoanalytiker würden sagen es ist
hoch neurotisch und wie wir da heraus
geführt würden indem wir uns herr lösen
wechselseitig im glauben an die liebe
das erzählung einzig die märchen dass
sie ihre eigentlich genau ich habe die
alte ausgabe mitgebracht hier der brüder
grimm die mich als kind begleitet hat
wir kommen zu einigen dieser märchen das
stand ich jetzt aber ich bin als kind
hört man einfach schön
geschichten wenn man diese dieses buch
als erwachsener schlägt denkt man ein
goethe da werden zehn abgeschnitten da
werden fersen war portieren da werden
leute umgebracht
da geht es aber auch zu und her kinder
wissen dass das symbole sind ohne es zu
danken
ich selber kann mich daran erinnern wie
1950 für mich im leben der unterschied
zwischen märchen sagen und den
zeitungsartikeln
bis dahin hatte ich geschichten dieser
art gelesen und plötzlich stand in der
zeitung in den tagen des koreakriegs
gemetzel um pusan
dann fragte ich meinen schatten was ist
das gemetzel der mann hatte zwei
weltkriege erlebt und er sagt er dass er
gleich ihr später das wollte mir nicht
erklären und ich ahnte dass das der
eintritt in eine wirklichkeit ist von
der ich bis dahin bildhaft erfahren
hatte das war spannend da konnte ich bei
seien aber jetzt strömten die flüsse in
südkorea von blut mann schoss in 40
kilometer entfernung in menschen hinein
und das war die wirklichkeit
ich habe die märchen nie anders
verstanden und die bibel schon mal gar
nicht als dass sie uns davor retten
könnten diese wirklichkeit normal zu
finden aber dann braucht man träume dann
braucht man visionen brauchen ein
fenster in den betondecken des irdischen
gefängnisses dann muss die fantasie die
auch gewalt konzipiert so organisiert
sein dass ein weg zur selbstfindung
daraus entsteht dann sind die feinde die
wir bekämpfen müssen teile unserer
eigenen seele niemals etwas draussen und
die gefahr ist riesig dass wir die
erwachsenen aus den märchen ein albtraum
der politik machen indem wir all das
nach draußen verlegen bis schon kampf
der sterne
also ich höre schon raus märchen sind
interpretationsbedürftig die bibel liegt
daneben wir werden die beiden durch auch
ins gespräch bringen jetzt aber erst
einmal themenschwerpunkt märchenhaft von
schweizer radio und fernsehen wir
tauchen ein in die welt der märchen der
brüder grimm und da in das märchen
schwesterchen und grübchen da schauen
wir den anfang an aus einer neueren
tv-verfilmung
es waren einmal in einem königreich zwei
kinder
brüderchen und schwesterchen die hatten
ihre liebe mutter verloren und ihr vater
seine geliebte frau
brüderchen und schwesterchen weilten
darüber viele tragen bitterlich und so
machte sich der vater schließlich auf
denen eine neue mutter zu suchen
und als er sie gefunden hatte kehrte er
mit ihr und ihrer tochter zurück design
award
[Musik]
heute war das finde ich auch
warum können wir die kartoffeln zu hause
am ofen rechten
lasst uns doch viel schöner
[Musik]
und es schmeckt ja auch viel besser
ja der böse blick der stiefmutter das
schicksal nimmt seinen lauf die
geschwister gehen wegbrechen wird in ein
reh verbandelt schwesterchen letztlich
vom könig dann erlöst stiefmutter mischt
sich noch mal ein
am schluss endet alles gut sie beide
werden erlöst in menschlicher gestalt
dann da sein
dieses märchen brüderchen und
schwesterchen dreht sich aber eigentlich
weniger wenn man so verlasen schade um
dieses geschwisterpaar sondern das ist
eigentlich wenn man mit dieser bösen
stiefmutter eigentlich sind brüderchen
und schwesterchen zwei facetten ein und
derselben person
man müsste sich geschwister in einer
person einer person innerhalb heranreift
um die liebe zu lernen und unter dem
einfluss der heimatlosigkeit des
verweist science in der vertauschung der
guten mutter gegen die böse mutter auf
der flucht vor sich selber ist die
stiefmutter hat alles was an lebendigen
in der welt wäre wie eine hexe
verwunschen unter schwesterchen lernt
sich selber abzuspalten
der eigentliche teil der in die welt
will voller sehnsucht voller verlangen
auch voller triebhaftigkeit im suche
nach der liebe wird abgespalten
marina in der gefahr raubtier haft zu
werden nochmal wie wird die mutter zur
stiefmutter
es kann einfach sein dass man älter wird
und mit dem erziehungsstil der mal
richtig war in der frühen kindheit nicht
länger zu recht kommt wenn man älter
wird
es kann buchstäblich sein dass die
mutter stirbt ein schicksal das um 1810
als dieses märchen verschriftlicht wurde
wie normal sein konnte den gebrüdern
grimm oder sind die eltern erst der
vater dann die mutter sehr früh
gestorben viele audio und genau das kann
die wirkliche erfahrung sein es kann
äußeren note der innerliche ein pass
dahin führen dass die mutter das nicht
mehr geben kann was hier eigentlich
möchte die mutter gestalt auf jeden fall
ist ambivalent und zwiegespalten wird
dann auch die seele dieses mädchens
eine hälfte die auf der suche nach der
liebe ist verwandelt sich in ein scheues
reh leyen ich habe da dieses schöne bild
hier gleich in dieser meiner kinder
ausgabe man dann sieht wie eben das
schwesterchen im dialog mit diesem see
line bezeichnet wird
es wäre wenn man so will ein tier
frieden inmitten der eigenen seele das
schwesterchen lehnt den kopf abends auf
das rehlein wie wenn es ein kissen wäre
und dieses scheue reh ist in der scheue
tiere ist das absichtlich gewählt
es ist der kompromiss statt eines
raubtiers wird jetzt ein eigentlich
ungefährliches fast zärtliches wesen
wenn man eine frau fragen würde was wäre
ihr lieblingstier und eine zauberin
könnte sie da hinein verwandeln während
nicht wenige die sagen wollten eine eine
re und verbänden der mit anmut grazie
lied schönheit sonst mut die wahrheit
ist das rehlein hier in dem märchen von
brüderchen und schwesterchen verhält
sich völlig anders als seine rechtes tun
würde
der jäger kommt der könig um in seinen
gold zu jagen und kaum bläst der der
stiftung bibel das rehlein auf leben und
tod es würde das hat mich auch
erstaunlich viele jana gehen und jetzt
muss man sich vorstellen man hatte ein
wunderschönes mädchen 18 jeweils 15
jährlich 25 jährige vor sich das in die
gestaltung eintritt nach draußen hat man
ein ungeheuer abenteuerlustige freudig
gejagt zu werden dass etwas das sich ins
leben stürzt förmlich umgesetzt zu
werden und die angstlust zu erleben dass
man es begehrt und immer möchte es im
letzten moment über ein gebüsch
entkommen das ist die eine seite
und man würde sich sehr identifiziert
man das wesen dass man da liebevoll und
verlockend vor sich sieht mit dem
schwesterchen das schockt voller angst
in seinem heußlein tiefen wandel und
will eigentlich nur den frieden haben
also wir sind mitten in einer
tiefenpsychologisch
die exegese die sie machen das rehlein
dass sich als leser einfach eben es ist
ein tier lese dass es jetzt für sie
einen anteil der seele unbedingt und
dazwischen liegen drei versuche aus den
wässern zu trinken
die von der zauberin verwunschen wurden
wer daraus trinkt verwandelt sich in
etwas unmenschliches tierisches und die
rege start ist das äußerste was nach
längeren trieb verzichten übrig bleibt
das rehlein wird verwundet werden auch
das kann man natürlich interpretieren
und es geht seine majestät auf die suche
wohin das rehlein sich wendet und
vernimmt wie man ein gut abgesprochen
hat blieb schwestern ein lasst mich
herein denn wenn du so nicht sprichst
das schwesterchen gesagt öffne ich mein
ziel ein die ihr nicht so kommt der
könig zur zu schwesterchen es ist das
wunder wie man die angst eines menschen
der abenteuerlustige scheint und im
hintergrund ganz zurückhaltend die es
fast regressiv noch in seiner eigenen
jugend und kindheit leben möchte und er
sich schützen will vor dem leben draußen
dass er doch herausfordert zugang
gewinnt um den preis dass man die angst
sprache versteht die rehlein sprache
es ist schon schwer genug normalerweise
die muttersprache eines menschen zu
begreifen was bedeutet wenn er davon
redet vater oder mutter oder schule oder
spiel oder freund wie belastet sich und
wie verdichtet sich mit seinen
erfahrungen
das muss man erst einmal ermitteln alle
worte sind wie wegweiser in einer
unbekannten zauberwelt also wie die
rehlein straßen mit anderen worten für
kinder ist er zum beispiel angst ein
großes thema sie müssen lernen damit
umzugehen weil das ein weg in diese
realen sprache wo dann der könig die
versteht wo das ins gespräch kommt wo es
dann integriert überwunden werden kann
das fatale ist die ansprache äußert
nicht das was zu sagen während man muss
die hintergründe hören vor einer weile
kam ich mit diesem märchen in der
psychotherapie ins gespräch mit einer
frau der ich das anbot rehlein sprache
sie sagte nämlich das kann man doch
nicht verstehen er hat angerufen aus
berlin und
hat gesagt was er der wichtiges tut in
der pause noch hat er sich die zeit
genommen
dann merkt er dass sie plötzlich sehr
traurig wird war beunruhigt erkennen sie
ihr ruf zwei stunden später noch mal an
und er lebt sie im chaos passiert war
dass er dauernd geschildert hat wie
wichtig er ist dabei hat sie zu hause so
viel getan das war ihm keine frage wert
es war ein machtgefälle dass sie schwarz
dass sie depressiv macht der hat es noch
gemeint hat aber diese sprache nicht
versteht es nur gut gemeint und hört
nicht gehört welche wünsche im
hintergrund sich melden
das wäre rein sprache das heißt sie
arbeiten mit märchen auch konkret in
ihrer therapeutischen praxis
das wäre das nicht gesagt dass nur als
verletzt sich zurückmelden das ihnen
sich verstellte vor angst und das
herauszulocken
und so leise an zu klopfen an die tür
des herzens ist dass sie sich von innen
her eröffnet das ist eine der kunstform
mit der hier der königssohn über den
reeder in dem schwesterchen begegnet
eine wunderbare sensibilität und respekt
eine scheune herzens einigkeit die man
eigentlich nur im verlauf von vielen
jahren sich erarbeiten kann
das geschieht hier in einem moment und
dann glaubt man als guter untertan jetzt
können wir die glückwunschkarte an den
hof schreiben genau die geniale zum hof
aber die stiefmutter schaltet sich
nochmal ein
es ist man beim vortrag eine frau zu
ihnen gekommen unter tränen haben sie
das beschrieben hätte sie gesagt sie
wäre eine stiefmutter und eigentlich
schon dann tragisch oder wenn man sowas
liest und selber den eindruck hat ich
habe nicht genügt oder was haben sie
gesagt hier die stiefmutter in
brüderchen und schwesterchen ist aus der
sicht des mädchens jedenfalls
tatsächlich bösartig der münchen und dem
t shirts besser als ich sage nicht die
kinder es ist pause
aber es gibt geschichten wie zum
beispiel bei aschenputtel wo ich glaube
dass die stiefmutter keine echte chance
hat das ist ein mädchen in dem die
mutter stirbt und das sich vollkommen
identifizierten in der mutter und dem
vater vorwirft dass er eine andere
geheiratet hat das mädchen ist drei zu
der verstorbenen mutter die im himmel
zuschaut
die jeden tag zum grad und der vater
wagt es übers jahr sich eine andere zu
nehmen
dieser vorwurf wird nie ausgeräumt die
stiefmutter müsste die identität dieses
mädchens völlig aufbrechen und das ging
nicht
solche geschichten sind sie einfühlsam
und ihr schicksal auch die tragödie
mancher gutmeinenden stiefmutter zu
verstehen
auch davon reden die märchen aber man
muss sie entsprechend abschließen
hier erleben wird dass man glücklich
verheiratet zu sein scheint man wird zur
königin man bekommt alles geschenkt
beneidenswert für jeden außenstehenden
und man wird zur mutter aber nur kurz
norma ziehen das jetzt geschildert
stiefmutter ist nicht gleich stiefmutter
bei den brüdern kriegen das ist so
wichtig weil man bekommt den eindruck
bei der oberflächlichen lektüre darm und
bei jedem ich weiß die zweite welt kommt
eine böse steht
was haben die brüder grimm für ein
problem mit steht mit dann es ist ein
stereotyp mit dem märchen reich gesegnet
sind und eben deshalb muss man
generation in den versierten beobachten
hier jetzt hat die stiefmutter nicht nur
die ganze welt verwunschen so dass die
kriegsgefahr das aufblühen zum frau sein
die sexualität ins tierische ins
dämonische abzugleiten droht es wird vor
allem im moment als der schwesterchen
eines kindes genesen ist die stiefmutter
zurückkehren das ist ein problem das in
so vielen familien geschieht habe ich
mich gefragt das märchen könnte dazu
ende sein dass das mädchen wird befreit
man könnte ja sagen ja rehlein wird
jetzt auch versteht die sprache
integriert sein und sieht man schön
verwandeln nein es geht dann hof das
spiel geht weiter
es ist ein schlüssel merken plötzlich
manche missratene ehe in der überhaupt
nicht begreifbar ist woran der scheitern
liegt das ist ein glücksmoment das
schwesterchen die frau die jetzt die
königin geworden ist gebührt ein kind
alle welt sollte sich darüber freuen
dass man nicht ahnt ist das eine
unglückselige kindheit eine verängstigte
beziehung zur eigenen mutter in der
gestalt der stiefmutter dahin führen
kann dem kind von herzen zu wünschen
dass es eine andere kindheit bekäme
also die mutter abzuarbeiten indem man
es richtig gut meint mit dem eigenen
kind man will ihm ersparen wollen man
selber leidet und unbewusst kehrt alles
zurück wogegen man anzukämpfen versucht
das bild ist grausam genau die
stiefmutter mischt sich einzig bringt
sogar ihre stieftochter mit von der man
nie gehört hat und mit mal verwandelt
sich die königin die doch der könig
liebt die er erlöst hat an der seite des
re line in ein schlossgespenst der
schwesterchen existiert überhaupt nicht
mehr
es meldet sich nur noch um zu schauen
wie es ihrem eigenen kind geht und jetzt
nimmt langsam abschied so kenne ich das
wirklich in manchen dass eine frau die
wie leer ist überarbeitet ist erschöpft
ist aus lauter guten willen
dabei ist ihrem mann wie in versform zu
schreiben dass vielleicht auf ihrem
grabstein stehen könnte um mitternacht
schemenhaft gibt es noch eine
erscheinung von dieser frau die
persönlich zu leben nicht gelernt hat da
mischt sich der könig sein
das erstaunliche ist er will dem spuk
standhalten und der entdeckt schließlich
aus dem gespenst seine ursprünglich
geliebte wieder
kann es sein dass man jahrelang als
ehemann zu der frau die man in die arme
geschlossen hat keinen kontakt mehr
findet weil sie in der mutterrolle
vollkommen aufgeht restlos absorbiert
ist dass man nur noch ihrem hintergrund
begegnet in gestalt der stiefmutter und
dann zurückkommen muss vielleicht nach
vielen jahren in dem man wieder redet
wir haben wir uns mal kennengelernt was
waren die gründe uns zu leben
wir sind wir denn wenn wir nicht nur in
der elternrolle aufgehen vielleicht nach
15 jahren 20 jahren wie können wir uns
befreien von dem spuk den wir gemacht
haben unter dem stress pflichtbewusst
verantwortlich unseren aufgaben
nachkommen zu müssen gewann nur in
funktion nur in dienst ich war könig du
warst mutter aber wir sind ja denn als
menschen aus dem märchen in der realität
liegt denn die lösung stiefmutter und
mutter werden ein sondern im grunde
würden sie beide integriert dabei in der
logik des märchens verschwindet einfach
die stiefmutter sie wird bestraft und
sie hat keine rolle mehr zu spielen
entscheidend ist dass die beiden sich
wieder erkennen dass man in dem das aus
dem andern geworden ist in der rolle der
mutter immer noch geahnt hat was an
liebe mal begriffen würde als man sich
begegnet und dass man das neu entdeckt
zur sprache bringt entzaubert und wieder
vermenschlicht was machen sie in so
einem fall in der praxis nehmen sie an
märchen versuchen das ist deutlich wird
geben sie einen hinweis an simons mal
dass im leben warten sie ist die person
das selber merkt was machen sie mit
ratschlägen ist wenig zu beginnen aber
die leute erzählen ihre geschichten so
dass es mir möglich wird die märchen als
ihr schicksal zu begreifen und die in
den interpretationen einzuflechten
und dann kann sich zurückmelden mit mal
kann ich dann tatsächlich sagen sie
kennen ihre geschichte und es ist es
nicht genauso
dann kann das märchen aus einsamkeit
erlösen den schieren geht es so lernt
man plötzlich und es gibt eine lösung
erzählt ja doch das märchen und man kann
darauf hoffen dass seine scheinbar schon
zerbrochene ehe die sich kaputt
gearbeitet hatte in ihren aufgaben
doch zurück findet zudem das mal gemeint
war die ursprüngliche schönheit geht
wieder die eigenen gefühle die mal waren
melden sich zurück die romantik der
ersten begegnung kann wieder entdeckt
werden
die ehe muss nicht dass sein dass ich
mein freund beschrieben wird im schatten
des wiederholungszwang es die endlos
sich im kreise drehen der
traumatisierung aus kindertagen ist es
möglich noch ein schritt zu tun indem
man integrativ zur persönlichkeit als
erwachsener wird der schlüssel dabei ist
dass das rehlein sich vermenschlicht und
aufhört nur in der tiergestalt am hof
geduldet zu werden
mit mal ist die frauen nicht nur als
frau zur mutter geworden sondern sie
kann als liebes partnerin ihr eigenes
rehlein erlösen und vermenschlichen
kindern
sind die beiden wirklich ein tal bis
dahin waren sie eine funktions
gemeinschaft zur erzeugung von kindern
das heißt irgendwann muss ja auch sagen
meine kinder ist abgeschlossen das und
das bringe ich mit und das und das mache
ich jetzt das ganz erstelltes mädchen in
symbolischen schritten den weg da der
dahin führt genau ein zuschauer schreibt
uns weil zweimal das erlösende wort ein
könig spricht oder in märchen einbringt
märchen alles schön und gut und der
zeitgeist verbrennt die latente und fast
universelle frauenfeindlichkeit frau
holle und so weiter ich schäme mich
meinen kindern und enkeln so etwas zu
erzählen
das wäre ein missverstandener männer
sind keine könige und die märchen
erzählen auch nicht vom hause winzer und
der heirat von drei jahren und was alle
noch schlucken könnte er in den gazetten
wir männer sind könige einzig nur in der
liebe einer frau die uns sehr zu füßen
legt und umgekehrt ist sie dann für uns
als geliebte eine königin die wir alles
was wir besitzen zu füßen legen
es ist die sprache der liebe wenn wir
einen anderen so hoch schätzen dass er
zu sagen hat in unserem leben
dann verwandelt sich die geliebte oder
der geliebte in ein könig und eine
königin
das ist nicht hoch herrschaftlich zu
verstehen sondern ganz und gar innerlich
und frauenfeindlich sind die märchen
überhaupt nicht frau holle wenn sie das
sieht ihren spiel gebaut nur unter
frauen und dazu tun mit dem problem der
gerechtigkeit frau handelt kann die
besten ihrer kinder nur stiefmütterlich
behandeln weil die frage ist wie man es
durch halt wie man die scheinbar an der
oberfläche so grausame welt vertieft die
goldmarie wie sie in dem parallel
erzählung heißt bei pechstein muss durch
den brunnen hinab fahnen und entdeckt
dann gewählt wir eine große wiese und
sie tut das richtige wenn es dran ist
wenn es befohlen wird nicht um belohnt
zu werden sondern einfach um gut zu sein
dem backofen der geleert sein bilden
etwa die reifen die zuhören was die
dinge brauchen
dafür war jetzt er dann belohnt aber
indirekt aber sie haben vorhin
gleichwohl haben sie geschmunzelt oder
sie können das schon verstehen dass von
außen kann man sagen dass das ist doch
irgendwie 1812 das erste mal erschienen
spiegel seiner zeit das ist doch die
frau an den herd natürlich sind die
rollenzuschreibungen in der romantik vor
200 jahren derart gewesen aber märchen
würden missverstanden wenn wir sie zeit
historisch und soziologisch relativieren
würden sie sagten eingangs völlig recht
die märchen beginnen mit es war einmal
und das bedeutet es war nie es ist immer
es ist etwas das dauernd in unser
versöhnlich spielt das als vergangenheit
sich aufbewahrt um die realität heute zu
interpretieren und gewissermaßen schon
die möglichkeiten zur erlösung
prognostisch in die zukunft zu richten
also ich habe gestaunt über den reichen
stoff der hier drin ist sie haben das
stichwort gerechtigkeit genannt wir sind
dabei den märchen der arme und der
reiche also wirklich ein super märchen
ihr habt das mit genuss wieder gelesen
da ist der liebe gott endlich der liebe
gott drin
und der ist als arme bettler oder aus
einfacher mensch unterwegs klopft bei
einem reichen
der vice dean abgeklopft bei einnahmen
da dafür übernachten wird bewirtet gibt
dann drei wünsche als die erfüllt auch
dann und bereiche hört davon bereitet
dem lieben gott hinterher und will
natürlich auch drei wünsche jetzt noch
äußern
der liebe gott sagte es wäre besser wenn
du es nicht tun würdest und macht dann
gleichwohl und die drei wünsche erweisen
sich dann doch eher als schräg denn als
segen für den reichen das märchen motiv
sei das verdienst so ernst genommen zu
werden als es möglich ist denn es hat
eine lange geschichte
die griechen konnten der vernetzung des
zeus über die welt geht und es gibt ein
einziges menschheit lich umfassendes
gebot selbst für die eltern vor troja
die an grausamkeiten schwer zu
überbieten sind das lautet
gastfreundschaft dh die märchen schöpfen
aus einem reichen vor
die sind ja nicht erfunden von den
brüdern grimm von vor tradition man
bedenken dass erzählt wurde in märchen
vom schon an den ersten feuern verfielen
jahr zehntausende das ist eine
vorstellung schicht eine ebene der
fantasie und des nächtens die uns als
menschheit vereint die dem gesamten homo
sapiens sapiens zumindest auf der ebene
des kommen junge menschen über 35.000
jahre eigen sein muss denn die kultur
entwicklung die sich daraus ergeben hat
fust in immer wieder vergleichbaren
erzählung rund um den globus dies nun
dass wir einen fremden begegnen und der
könnte sein ein gott der uns trifft für
die güte wieder aufgenommen wird ist ein
motiv das in der alten welt wie
selbstverständlich war auch die juden
können davon erzählen dass gott
unterwegs ist wo er aufnahme fände zu
suchen und das wird hier beschworen
das hat auch biblisches format wenn man
liest matthäus 25 ich war fremd oder ich
war hungrig ich war durstig und die
entscheidende frage was hier vermehrt
die gastfreundschaft ist an diesen
kulturen wird hoch geschrieben oder wenn
wir zulassen oder realisieren wir dass
wir selbst in homers odyssee ist es
möglich am ufer der verkehr in recess
einer schein der gott wäre denn so sind
sie die gatter sie sitzen neben uns in
der gestalt von fremden und warten
darauf dass man sie erkennt aber jetzt
entscheidend es kann im grunde nicht
hochherrschaftlich der reiche den armen
als die gottes gestellt erkennen offen
der gottheit zu begegnen indem hits
bedürftigen ist eigentlich nur wirken
seine eigene hilfsbedürftigkeit weiß und
wer sie nicht verleugnet die typologie
des reichen die so alt ist wie es im
antiken ägypten schon der fall eine
schablone um reich zu werden in dieser
welt muss man im grunde skrupellos
grausam korrupt und verlogen sein sonst
geht es nicht mit ehrlichen meint nicht
nur geld und natürlich innerlich genauso
aber um sie in dieser welt zu etwas zu
bringen kann man nicht mit ehrlicher
arbeit fahren kommen das sieht man
gesichter botschaften sind wie die
sklaven ganz unten und gehe da oben
sagen wir in unseren tagen die bankiers
mit den boni von millionen womit
verdienen die das da muss man
misstrauisch sein und so formt sich die
schablone zwischen arm und reich und
mächtig und ohnmächtig unter drogen- und
das sind schon in der gegenwart
drewermann aber hier warum ist gott ein
einfacher mensch und man kommt eher
selten vor ihren eigentlich wäre gott
theologisch derjenige der alles zu geben
hat und das zeigt sich auch aber die art
wie gott schenkt ist als erstes die gabe
dass wir erkennen wir selber sind mir
ist das ein wunderbares wort weil es am
anfang der kondensation der ganzen
botschaft jesus steht in der bergpredigt
übersetzt das ein bisschen frei
glücklich nenne ich die menschen die
ihre armut kennen und anerkennen
wir entdecken dass wir fehlerhaft sind
schwachsinn rom mächtig sein können und
wir kämpfen dagegen an um etwas
darzustellen und gemeinden sind wie
liebenswert wenn wir etwas zu bieten
haben wenn wir nach außen realisieren
und wir werden dabei nicht ehrlich wir
werden immer noch schablonen suchen die
kaschieren wer wir wirklich sind und je
erfolgreicher desto fataler man kann mit
der lüge sagt man in russland um die
ganze welt kommen man kommt nur nicht
bei sich selber an die armut
anzuerkennen wäre die öffnung dafür dass
die anderen nicht anders hin als wir
auch und jeder lebt im grunde von einer
anti sich ausstreckt auf der suche wie
man helfen kann dort wo der andere
hilfsbedürftig ist das ist inhalt der
menschlichkeit der religion der
ehrlichkeit sich selber gegenüber
wir sind nicht hier es geschafft haben
und dann herabschauen könnten zu den
andern der waren der reichen allerdings
in anführungsstrichen jetzt erreichen
wir verdanken es sich selber sie haben
es geschafft den american way of life
zum profit gemacht und jetzt beherrschen
sie die anderen können sie demütigen und
sich alles leisten auf kosten anderer
dann steht der liebe gott daneben und
schreibt was aus uns geworden ist ich
möchte noch auf einsatz zu kommen wir
erkennen wer wir selber sind das größte
geschenk dass gott uns machen kann weil
es erlaubt in gnade zu denken wir wären
akzeptiert einfach so wie wir geschaffen
würden aber er kennt der reiche sich
absolut nicht und daran liegt ja das
problem er glaubt dass man eh liefert
werden erreicht um schritt wenn er gross
wird wenn er nach außen repräsentativ
wird wenn er lauter das tut was wir in
aller regel unseren kindern schon
beibringen die nicht die märchen lesen
und ganz sicher nicht erklärt bekommen
also erreichtet dann wieder zurück
überlegt sich die längste zeit was es
sich wünschen könnte nämlich möglichst
viel reichtum aber wie stelle ich das an
und das pferd was macht dauernd
irgendwas und dann der reihe nach der
arme wie selbstverständlich nimmt den
herrgott bei sich auf ohne zu wissen
dass er es ist und gibt sich alle mühe
er muss lang gelaufen seine wird fast
erschöpft sein also gibt er ihm sogar
sein eigenes bett und was er zu essen
hat wie selbstverständlich dann erst
zeigt sich dass derjenige der mann
beherbergt hat nicht nur ein sendbote
gottes ist ein verborgener engel sondern
gott selber um nun darf man wünschen und
was der arme wünscht ist eigentlich das
er zusammen mit seiner frau möglichst
leben könnte man dürfte hinzufügen ohne
dass er um die altersrente betteln muss
ohne dass er zu früh am stock gehen als
einfaches leben ein einfaches aber
jegliches leben
die irgendwas wir nicht kaum vermutet
oder jetzt denkt das ist 200 jahre her
das geht uns nichts mehr an
es gehört zum selbstverständnis jesus
arm um die seligkeit nach dem tode
nur in dem vertrauen dass es eine welt
gäbe jenseits dieser welt erlaubt es in
ruhe und den frieden die wenigen
jahrzehnte hier auf erden und verkrampft
und ohne gier so wie es ist sich zu
bewegen
dieses vertrauen darauf dass am ende
wenn sich die türe öffnet hier in die
augen dessen schauen der gewollt dass
wir sind
in seiner güte erlaubt es diese strecke
auf erden menschlich zu bestehen
damit überhaupt nicht dann müssen wir
die welt aus passen dass hier hergibt
was sie niemals bieten wird nämlich
glück genau damit unterläuft auch noch
die religionskritik oder die später zum
teil auch dann noch sagt eben das ewige
auf das jenseits hofen entwertet das
diesseits der kümmert sich ja der arme
oder genau gerade umgekehrt das
vertrauen darauf dass gott ewig ist und
uns in empfang nimmt in dieser güte die
nicht vergeht erlaubt uns menschlich zu
sein mitten in der armut großzügig und
gütig zu sein
wie überhaupt unverkrampft als mensch
sich zu schenken und der reiche eben
dass du dummes pferd ich wünsche dir den
tod an den haltung tod fällt um
es ist möglich dass man in so einer gier
als reicher weil es eine andere welt
überhaupt nicht gibt aus den paar
jahrzehnten die wir hier sind als aus
hessen muss dann gibt es keine
grausamkeit die nicht erlaubt ist dann
ist die konkurrenz des 1 gegen den
anderen dann muss man um das leben
kämpfen und dem anderen noch auf den
kopf treten damit man noch eine sprosse
auf der karriereleiter höher geht es
gibt nur diese welt begreifen sie nur
den materialismus die abschaffung steht
fest die sinnlosigkeit ist objektiv
gegeben
bei ihm stehenden menschen dann auch
noch im dienst dieser ganzen geschichte
wünscht sich dann noch die frau auf den
sondern weil er denkt dies in ruhe zu
hause genießt das leben selbst wenn
jemand käme der alle wünsche erfüllen
würde der reiche begreift nicht dass es
gut wäre das von güte die rede geht es
nur ein magisches instrument so weiter
zu machen und dann waren die ihn in den
märchen der liebe gott er soll nur nicht
wünschen er wird dann seinen eigenen
wünschen unglücklich werden das ist die
art wie gott den märchen straft er fügt
nicht von außen etwas zu dann wünschte
die frauen natürlich von sattel runter
wer nach hause kommt also keinen wunsch
nach ewigem reichtum usw sieht die
strafe erwähnen sie haben sich ja ein
leben lang gegen einen strafenden gott
sie haben versucht ein leben lang aus
der bibel heraus die hand
herauszufiltern aber subtil ist er hier
auch der strafende gott bamberg die
menschen können nur weise werden indem
sie an den folgen ihrer eigenen
innerlich verkrampften einstellung
leider dann durch schaden und durch
schmerzen zur weisheit kommen mehr kann
man nicht tun als zu sagen
die welt anders zu sehen der reiche ist
und deshalb im widerspruch mit sich weil
sein pferd sagen wer seine ganze
vitalität seine triebe natur nicht mehr
verträgt derart über stress zu sein
es baut auf das rebelliert sein eigenes
pferd es bricht zusammen also stellen
sie sich vor er sieht etwas passiert und
wird nicht schlau daraus stellen sie
sich vor jemand leidet mit 56 ein
klassisches alter für männer märz
infarkte hat alles getan ist weit
gekommen ist wirklich reich er macht und
er weiß vor seiner tür schon scharen sie
um seinen stuhl zu besetzen und er
kämpft bis zum zusammenbruch
das pferd liegt da er selbst am boden
dann wird dann noch den sattel schmidt
schleppen um nichts zu verpassen um nur
ja kein verlust zu haben er wird sich
selber zu schwer
und dann wird da neidisch und
hasserfüllt seine frau hat scheinbar
besser für winter denn das als er kann
nur noch fluchen und verwünschen und der
letzte wunsch wird sein dass zumindest
die fehler seiner wünschbar keiten
revidiert die frau will natürlich vom
sattel und damit dass da nichts als
plagen und schaden im teufelskreis
seiner eigenen so eng gewordenen welt
daraus zu öffnen wäre der sinn der
geschichte vom armen und formaten es
könnte so einfach sein
man könnte arm sein und gleichzeitig
wirklich und eigentlich nur diejenigen
die es lernen in diesem sinn ihre armut
zu akzeptieren haben das zeug dazu ja
auch mal zu widerstehen den schaden der
konkurrenz zu widerstehen sich selber
anzunehmen und den anderen nicht niedrig
machen zu müssen um selber groß zu
werden
das leuchtet ein aber nochmal hier
matthäus 25 das steht eigentlich genau
das gleiche wie hier wenn es zum end
gericht kommt das kriterium was du einen
meiner geringsten
getan hast hast du mir getan matthäus 25
40 das ist peinlich genau das gleiche
kriterium dass wir hier finden wir in
diesem märchen das endet aber mit einem
mit einer scheidung von gut und böse
für einen auf die linke seite die haben
auf die rechte seite und hier drinnen
diesen leicht pädagogisch strafenden
gott akzeptieren sie dass sie aber nicht
auch die bibel der gleichnisse aspekt
haft und nicht total deshalb appiah
begonnen mit der seligpreisungen jesu
natürlich gibt es arm und reich aber
bevor man das übersetzt in die moral wie
verhalte ich mich jetzt nach dem maßstab
der güte oder der humanität ist es vor
entscheidend wie wir zu uns selber
stehen wie wir unsere eigene armut
anerkennen und akzeptieren und das ist
ein vorgang der quasi therapeutisch ist
wir müssten in einen raum in einer asyl
städte ein klären dürfen in die edition
selber beginn ehrlich zu sein solange
wir angst haben werden wir auf der
flugzeuge für uns selber werden wir uns
als schande erleben wir sind nicht schön
genug nicht stark genug nicht
intelligent genug nie gut genug es nie
genug also müssen wir irgendwas machen
und immer weiter weichen wir von uns ab
jede psychotherapie ist eine lücke in
die erlaubnis des vertrauens wir sind im
grunde gut genug
es kann nicht besser werden als wir sind
und damit einverstanden zu werden ist
die vorbedingung das eigentliche wunder
im neuen testament von dem jesus dann
redet wenn das ihm vertrauen zu gott als
seiner väterlichen hintergrund gestellt
der vergebung gelernt und aufgenommen
würde dann kann man die geschichte
erzählen wie es weitergeht
sonst steht sie wirklich isoliert da und
man hat weder eine werke ethik unter
absoluten moralischem anspruch
dann macht es angst ich erzähle nochmal
aus den brüdern grimm eine andere
geschichte die treulich wiedergibt was
an bester reformatorischer theologie von
luther bis calvin die theologen zu
lehren versuchte aber selten so einfach
wie die brüder grimm die geschichte
weniger bekannt vom schneider im himmel
eine parabel auf unser leben irgendwann
kommen wir an die himmelstür dahin führt
jeder lebensweg und der wird uns
begleiten fast erschöpft
wir könnten nicht mehr weiter der
schneider weil es so ist klopft an und
petrus hütet die himmelspforte und darf
laut göttlichen befehl niemanden
einlassen denn der herr ist gerade mit
den aposteln im garten spazieren gehen
und so lange sollte niemand fremdes da
hinein
petrus fasst die nachfolge gestalt des
papstes heute man sollte denken die
verkörperung gottes auf erden wagte es
an dieser stelle dem göttlichen befehl
durch handel zu gesprächen mit einem
einzigen motiv der schneider kann
wirklich nicht weiter er verdient mit
leid und er muss nicht noch weiter
ziehen es gebe eine ausnahme sitzt was
gott geboten hätte verdient
überschritten zu werden wenn es geht um
mit leute und güte das tut hier petrus
wie anders sähe unsere welt aus unsere
gesellschaft unsere kirche unsere
politik alles wenn wir an der
himmelspforte jemanden hätten der selbst
die weisung gottes über treten würde
angesichts der hilfsbedürftigkeit eines
menschen und nun im ernst nur so kämpfe
in den himmel
nicht weil wir es verdient hätten weil
wir so famose ordentliche christen oder
juden oder muslime werden nur wenn gott
sich unser erbarmt darin sehen sie ein
aspekt eben der reformatorischen
theologie die betont dass wir aus gnade
geheilt werden und der saft aus eigener
leistung genau und das sag nicht erst
die reformatorische theologie sie kann
sich voll berufen auf das neue testament
das einzige weswegen wir lernen mit uns
über einzustimmen und glücklich zu
werden ist das wir glauben können an
gottes güte ein motiv auch in den
weihnachtstagen jetzt herrlichkeit ist
gott im himmel nur für frieden ist wenn
einheit ist bei menschen auf erden die
am gottes güte glauben kann so
übersetzte ich den satz einmal sinngemäß
das zu ermöglichen ist für den schneider
gerade passiert und jetzt ist die frage
wie wir damit umgehen neugierig setzt er
sich auf gott ist
und von da aus kann man alles sehen was
auf erden passiert fast magisch nach
gott braucht wieder pharao den thron
damit er weiß was los ist
und der sieht eher wie eine frau
textilien stiehlt ein schleier eine
hässliche alte unterwirft er mit dem fuß
kämen nach ihr um gerechtigkeit zu üben
ich behaupte seit 1789 seit den tagen
der aufklärung am wir geglaubt die
religion ist passé jetzt haben wir die
vernunft und die moral und das gesetz
wer etwas schlechtes tut wird bestrafen
oder beschert des wird es sind tolle
bilder oder chemie gottes wird
runtergeschmissen als ersatz für gott
wenn wir uns an dem platz setzen wo wir
gott als güte vermuten müssten bleibt
nur eine todes gefährliche gerechtigkeit
der große idealist und eine meiner
großen lehrer immanuel kant konnte sagen
wenn jemand zum start aus gründen der
gerechtigkeit zum tode verurteilt ist
muss er am vormittag noch hingerichtet
werden selbst wenn der staat sich am
nachmittag auflösen würde das ist
gerechtigkeit da gibt es keine ausnahme
es hat nichts zu tun mit der
armseligkeit der menschen die gütig nur
werden können durch güte die nur reichen
können ihn mitleid wenn sie es erfahren
haben
und das wäre der eigentliche religiöse
hintergrund davon erzählt ein kleines
märchen schmunzelnd denn der schneide
bekommt von gott gesagt wenn ich so
richten wollte wie du richtest hätten
wir hier kein es besteht keine ofen gabe
nicht so dass alles nach den leuten die
was falsch machen schmeißen müsste er
himmel wer kein himmel mehreren so
gerichtet würde und wer käme denn da
auch immer da geht es uns doch oft so
oder dass wir denken das geht doch nicht
darum stellt ein kleines märchen die
ganze jurisprudenz im abendlichen in
frage und endet mit dem was am schluss
der bergpredigt steht richtet ihr
überhaupt gar nicht denn sonst müsste
gott euch richten nach gleichem maße ab
und dann buchstäblich gnade euch kommt
ein kleines märchen das die kirche in
frage stellt mit dem bild des petrus der
gütig sein kann
die tugend moral der aufklärung in frage
stellen geht die brüder grimm gerade vor
sich oder hinter sich haben
der die praxis unserer gesellschaft
infrage stellt die sich aufgeklärt gibt
die den terror der fall nun schlittere
der leistung und der französischen
revolution wie ein donnerschlag noch
gerade beseitigt durch eine
humoristische erzählung was wir wirklich
brauchen
das können märchen sie haben ja die
kirche angesprochen sie sind vor zehn
jahren ausgetreten aus der katholischen
kirche
denken sie manchmal wenn wir so reden im
hintergrund an ihre eigene geschichte
eine befreiungs geschichte von wie sie
in einen biblischen und religiösen und
kirchen dogmen
ich bin davon überzeugt dass man die
bibel die botschaft gottes gründlich
missverstehen wenn man sie nicht
poetisch und symbolisch liest wenn man
sie fixiert zu historischen tatsachen
und topmotiviert zur vernunft wahrheiten
die man dann halt beweisen könnte im
unterschied zu allen anderen religionen
dann ambitioniert man die religion so
ein kampfinstrument das recht haben dann
ist sie grausam und die intoleranz egal
wie sie sich gibt dann ist ein
unendlicher vorzug dass wir dogmatisch
christen würden und verlangen nicht mehr
was es bedeutet menschlich zu sein im
sinne jesu die märchen versteht jeder
die gleichnisse jesu versteht jeder weil
ein mensch ist dafür braucht man keine
dummen und dass jesus als menschensohn
im neuen testament bezeichnet wird heißt
doch wohl dass er uns ermöglichen möchte
soll über menschen zu sein und die
einzige frage ist denn auch so wie
vermenschlicht man das gottesbild so
dass wir die gute laune die wir brauchen
gegen die angst die uns zu deutschland
machen könnte
dies muss alle eines tages gedacht ich
muss ja mal ballast abwerfen
ich selber hat für mich überhaupt kein
ballast abwerfen müssen aber ich wollte
dass ich die märchen die ich als kind in
gewissem sinn geglaubt habe nicht
verloren und bei der bibel ganz genau so
wie es mir costa ich hätte nicht leben
können ohne die botschaft jesu die
wollte ich weiter halten
gegen die welt in der sie interpretiert
wird interpretiert wurde dass krieg sein
kann aus gründen der gerechtigkeit
das war 1955 dass ein katholik nicht das
recht hat den medien zu verweigern
in einem angriffsfall wo der staat sich
vor
regieren muss ich habe damals den buga
gebraucht und klaut sie indische und
chinesische weisheit um zu sagen das
kann so nicht stimmen
ich wollte mit meinen jesus nicht rauben
lassen was die mädchen angeht hat erich
kästner mal ganz schön gesagt in
derselben zeit der konnte übrigens da
dichten als die kirche zum atomkrieg die
bereitschaft zeigte jetzt kein fluchen
und kein beten die sache stimmt der
liebe gottes aus der kirche ausgetreten
und schrieb gleichzeitig wären er
erwachsen wird aufhört das kind zu
bleiben dass er einmal war
hört auf ein mensch zu sein das ist was
ich in der psychotherapie immer wieder
erlebe wir müssen anknüpfen denn das was
verloren ging als man uns beibrachte
erwachsen zu werden chipkarten gerecht
den industriestandort deutschland zu
verteidigen
die sieben jahren zu denken was wir mit
67 jahren als rentenempfänger machen das
alles wahnsinn
wir waren wir mal was wäre mit uns
gemeint gewesen welche hoffnung zogen
wie uns welche ängste sind uns damals
geworden die das leben bis heute
verfahren und nun können wir es neu
lernen das machen die märchen auf ihre
weise die pläne mutterland die geliebte
wieder zu werden als die sie mal in die
arme geschlossen wurde
es hört die spuck gestalt von
entsetzlichen ängsten aus kindertagen
auf zu existieren
es ist möglich und sei es im himmel die
güte zu langen den mann auf erden schwer
vermisst es ist möglich mitten in der
armut die am seligkeit zu begreifen die
nur in der güte lebensfähig bleibt bei
der armut die haben ja über ein faxgerät
ist nicht mal bei ihnen steht
kommuniziert sie haben keinen
kühlschrank kein auto kein computer kein
internet kein
mail kann mit einem wort ich lebe so wie
es manche klöster anbieten sehr teuer
ich glaub 3000 euro kann das kosten für
14 tage regeneration aufenthalt ich
finde dass man das auch normalerweise
kann indem man gar nicht in anspruch
nimmt als überflüssig sie sind
vegetarier haben sie eines tages das
märchen vom armen und reichen gelesen
und sich gesagt der albert recht das war
für mich ein grundproblem ich habe nie
verstanden wie es ein gutes recht sein
kann leben zu töten
sogar unter quelle rischen bedingungen
zu halten und fühlende wesen das waren
doch unsere hühner das war meine katze
man kann doch damit nicht so umgehen
dass man sie eigentlich nur um sie zu
töten und auszubeuten helden dann kam
wieder kirchenbeamte die erklärten so
hat gott die welt geschaffen
der mensch ist der höhepunkt
erschöpfungs pyramide wörtliches zitat
aus einer dogmatik vorlesung von
jemandem der später bischof wurde dem
hasen kann nichts besseres passieren als
dass er in der pfanne landet köstliches
gelächter bei den zu hören
ich war in vendig hilflos ich dachte
wenn man muss unrecht haben natürlich
ist dass die schöpfungsordnung natürlich
ist das darwin natürlich ist das kampf
ums dasein natürlich frist ein tier das
andere aber wir menschen hätten mal die
chance da herauszutreten stadt den
darwinismus für die gottes ordnung zu
erklären das ist ein altes problem um
200 nach christus hat marion diesem buch
zum ersten mal formuliert aber die
kirche hat die nie begriffen wie kann
ein gott der güte dieser welt geschaffen
haben das ist ein riesiges problem und
daraus erwächst atheismus die leute
schauen sich um und jeweils ist
gründlich anders als das hier eine
manifeste nach lohn der güte und der
weisheit war aber grundgelegt diesen
beiden büchern auch eine andere vision
nämlich das gespräch zb zwischen mensch
und tier
kommen wir noch zu einem anderen märchen
zu ihrem ersten gesprächen wissen der
sogar jemand papst wehrt bloß weil er
die sprache der tiere kennt genau wer
noch ein schönes märchen
wir schauen uns aber ein ausschnitt aus
schneewittchen noch an
der film mit mir zu deutsch spieglein
spieglein vom aus dem jahr 2011 von
thorsten sing mit julia roberts als
stiefmutter und lily collins übrigens
der tochter von phil collins als
schneewittchen fließt du vor einem feuer
wie bitte
[Musik]
lotet in deinem zimmer ein feuer
ich suche nämlich nach einer erklärung
warum du hier bist anstatt in deinem
zimmer und mein erster gedanke war feuer
ich dachte vielleicht durfte ich mit
feiern zumal heute doch ein 18 tag
geburtstag ist du meine güte du meine
güte
nach 11 3 bitte vielleicht sollte ich
wirklich etwas weniger streng mit ihr
sein zumal du mir nichts angetan hast
mein kind keinerlei probleme bereit ist
und dennoch hast du etwas merkwürdiges
anti rhd es so unglaublich befremdlich
ist ich weiß nicht was vielleicht die
plumpen schultern deinhardt deine stimme
ich weiß was es ist
ich glaube es ist wenn ich hasse dein
haar und wenn es dein 100 stück butter
quere
julia roberts darf mal eine böse rolle
spielen
es wird dann aber gerechtigkeit
hergestellt also schneewittchen erobert
sich in dem film und dem märchen den
prinzen gerechtigkeit das tut sie um
einen preis den man niemand wünschen
würde bei der leider gerade auch in
unseren tagen von so vielen vor allem
mädchen und frauen gefördert wird
jetzt haben wir uns die geschichte mal
in ihrer ganzen dialektik die
stiefmutter hier julia roberts ist eine
wunderschöne frau die vor dem spiegel
immer wieder das echo hören möchte die
allerschönste zu sein und dann wird ihre
eigene stieftochter ihr gefährlich es
könnte die jugend ihr zur konkurrenz
werden
schon sind wir bei einem hauptproblem
heute anti aging bedeutet dass wir jede
art von beauty farm als pflicht
entbinden wir müssen uns durch halten
wir dürfen nicht altern wir müssen
bleiben wie wir sind sonst verlieren wir
die zuneigung männer lieben
grundsätzlich nur jüngere bilden sich
manche frauen 1
von teur zärtlichkeit gemeinsamkeit gar
keine rede mehr
in dieser welt hinein kommt nun ein
mädchen und die spannung in der
grimmschen erzählung ist dass die mutter
alles tut die tochter schön
herauszustreichen aber sie schafft damit
nur angst schneewittchen flieht vor weil
sie eine mörderin ist sie kann nicht
leben an der seite dieser mutter und
regiert in ihre eigene kindheit ihr
neues wagen wird da ist sie unschuldig
der muss sie noch nicht frau werden da
reift sie nicht heran zu den erfahrungen
die es bedeutet erwachsen zu sein
auf dem weg dahin bekommt verzaubert in
der gestalt einer marke denn darin eine
händlerin die eigene mutter wieder
und was sie jetzt probiert sind alle
guten ratschläge wie man sich als frau
herausputzt hier bringt mit einer schnur
leid wenn man sich so zurück das thalia
und busen schön geformt sind
man kriegt keine luft mehr wenn es so
eng wird sie bringt mit ein kampf wie
man die haare die irre geführt
anklang so heraus streichelt dass sie
wirkung haben
vor den augen der männer soll man denken
aber der kam ist vergiftet schließlich
bringt sie den apfel den apfel der liebe
muss man denken mit und er ist zur
hälfte wieder vergiftet und
schneewittchen fällt in den tod dabei
der zustand dann entsprechend für das
was man mit vielen heute macht
schneewittchen wird ein gesagt in glas
sie ist lebendig tot und nur noch eine
figur zum zu stellen
das kleine kinder ist zwar klein sind
todunglücklich darüber wie sie können
diesen bruch diese angst auf dem weg zum
erwachsenwerden nicht mehr korrigieren
das ist eine schönheit die sich nie
wagen darf er malte 16 jährige die von
casting zu casting streuen um die
schaufensterpuppen genau diesem ideal zu
entsprechen
sie sind hinter glas sichtbar aber sie
dürfen nicht leben
sie müssen sich im kreise drehen sie
müssen perfekt sein sie müssen auf den
catwalk standhalten sie müssen jeder
kritik der in einer dreckigen jenny
standhalten als die besten und die
schönsten und nur die besten werden
genommen das ist dein leben
sie leben wird ein schneewittchen
moderne sie werden richtig emotional
bekommen habe schon langsam zum haus
laut gleichzeitig darüber dass am ende
jemand kommt ja selber der lösung bei
gottfried von hat der name ist der bau
musaeus der entdeckt wie auf einer
busfahrt für seinen vater der natur
wünschen könnte der schneewittchen im
gläsernen sarg und weiß er muss es
erlösen sonst wird er seine seele nicht
finden und sein vater nicht erlösen
und dann möchte er es kaufen ein ganz
moderner zug unsere welt was schön ist
kann man kaufen ist überhaupt nur schön
wenn man es kaufen kann und nun haben
wir ein winziges märchen einer person
schneewittchen jetzt weigern sich das
wesen das sie lieb haben und dass sie in
seiner kindlichen unschuld bewahren
möchten ganz so verankern auf dem markt
ist unverkäuflich und nur geschenkt kann
schneewittchen von gott schrieb fonda
dennis von den prinzen mitgenommen
werden und dann ist es auf seinen
schultern das ist doppelt und aus
bericht was an der apfel grids in seinem
hals geblieben ist das gift
psychotherapeutisch ist das ein langes
bemühen
sprechen sie auch sagen sie ist unfertig
lassen sie sich zweite sind sätze die
keine sätze sind es in worte die kein
gefüge ergeben es ist ansprache rehlein
sprache was auch immer aber es bricht
sich aus es fand sich langsam es regt
sich wieder leben und die geduld muss
sein der mit am ende schneewittchen frei
wird von all den erstickenden
schönheitswahn es seiner mutter die tage
noch sagte meine frau für meine mutter
war nur das beste gut genug und damit
wollte sie sagen ich war es nie noch
eine erlösung geschichte zum schluss
kurz was ist ihnen jetzt mehr wir haben
hier die brüder grimm märchen wir haben
hier die bibel
natürlich ist die bibel mehr weil sie
tiefer lotet die märchen beschreiben
unser leben mit bestimmten
randbedingungen aber sich vielen auf dem
tor an der psyche die bibel erweitert
unser leben auf die ent fragen hin wie
es die märchen nicht können verdammt ist
der bibel der mythos und das ist eine
andere erzählform die bilder sind sehr
austauschbar und identisch und ich
behaupte man wird die bibel nur richtig
verstehen wenn man die märchen zumindest
interpretieren kann ich begreife die
theologen auf den katheder nicht gemein
die sprache gottes zu verstehen wenn sie
sich außerstande zeigen auch nur
interesse geschweige fähigkeit zu
besitzen
den traum aus der letzten nacht in der
seele ihrer eigenen studentinnen und
studenten zu erhöhen wenn sie sich
weigern die kinder sprache zu begreifen
darin redet gott und als jesus gefragt
wird nein das kapitel bei markus worauf
kommt es an ihm leben wird er genauso
sagen wenn ihr es nicht land wieder zu
werden wir die kinder ihr werdet gott
nicht begreifen ihr könnt den
himmelreich nicht eingehen so ernst ist
dass die bibel so zu lesen wie würden
sie gottes märchenbuch in unserer seele
wäre der traum unseres schöpfers in
beringen das bliebe uns zum leuchten
käme was gemeint ist
eugen drewermann gleichwohl ist die
bibel ja kein märchen sie haben die
psychotherapie und die theologie
miteinander ins gespräch gebracht sie
habe auch die märchen und die bibel
miteinander ins gespräch gebracht
herzlichen dankeschön die wirsberger
hier geht es gleich weiter mit einer der
großen fragen der stunde
wie soll europa mit der wachsenden
negation umgehen mit dem historiker
philipp blom in der sternstunde
philosophie
[Musik]